[Music]
in uber dilemma new submitted by a best
Basten accent oh child best Boston
accent I know I was trying to do it was
so bad and I don't know what things I
can't do it oh I heard something way off
fasted yes I knew what she was trying to
do yeah a child died after taking an
uber alone oh [ __ ] but drivers say they
can't afford to reject kids dude uber is
so scary that he got kidnapped
was it the driver he was crazy did he
need an EpiPen oh you thought you wanted
a whole other way he's always kids
needing [ __ ] epi pens yeah oh all
right so this was a 12 year old girl who
took an uber by herself two days after
she installed the app on her mom's phone
without her mom knowing and she used a
gift card that she had received as a
gift and she took this uber to go to
this parking structure and she killed
herself oh my god that's not what I was
thinking at all yeah Wow what the [ __ ]
so it didn't happen in the uber like no
so they're just using that and like she
got there through over yeah she went
through she were to got there on bicycle
but by walking a problem was it over
well it is because it's against uber
policy to accept minors all by
themselves the drivers are saying like
listen yeah we shouldn't be picking up
minors and yeah you're telling us not to
but there's all these these consequences
that happen if we if we deny a ride you
having a charge rating and then they
won't get the cancellation fee like the
drivers have to go after uber to get the
cancellation fee that they're owed even
if it's like because they they've just
recently put the option like under like
the reason why you're cancelling and
that's because it's a minor yeah they
also have this thing for drivers where
if you accept three rides in a row you
end up getting certain rewards or like
consecutive ride bonus yeah and so
you'll get extra pay but if drivers
cancel for any reason even if it's an
unaccompanied minor they miss out on the
additional money there's like all these
other things that are preventing uber
drivers to really follow the policies
because they rely so heavily on getting
paid yeah and I feel like most of the
time when you're a minor right it's like
to go to the mall or to Oh to his
friend's house because my brother uses
that for that parents I have an uber
picked their kid up because they can't
make it I feel like the parent right now
in this situation is probably just
looking for anyone to blame it on and
it's like you should not have attempted
that right of course and then they're
saying that they strongly believe that
uber took their daughter to the point of
no return by accepting the right so they
are saying that they never saw any signs
and their daughter that she wanted to
kill herself that she they didn't see
any of that are they even around to see
that no rather kids don't just naturally
oh yeah are we allowed to ask how she
passed away I actually don't be this
insane I don't know I feel like if there
was a plan of action like she jumped
from somewhere she could have done it
from her house you know like she didn't
necessarily need to go to a parking
structure yeah that's tough but they do
say that she was there like you know how
could you pick up this kid who's clearly
underage and she's like 4 foot 11 inches
7th grader and like you know it's your
fault pretty much and this is early
early early in the morning but it's
horrible so that she decided to take a
ride into downtown Orlando to go to this
parking garage and do what she did so
she why that specific garage yeah and
like she knows it was an address so I
was Florida again hmm
but dude 12 years old and you're like
doing this elaborate plan to like put
the credit or the gift card and like use
your mom's phone get a ride and be like
all right thanks for the ride and then
just like go up on a building like how
do you even have that much emotion at 12
you know there's suicide that like way
younger than yeah bullying and stuff
like that is a huge thing that you can't
see life outside of their school
situation that's what can crease you do
the dad the girl's dad said that their
daughter wrote in a suicide note that
she thought she would have more
difficulty getting an uber and that she
was basically passed
we'll return now no oh they're like we
want to stop like if she couldn't get
the uber she wouldn't have done it that
kind of what the - she could have walked
there wrote in there that's a lot of
misplaced blame yeah she was like all
right at the zubur accepts my right I'm
doing it and it means it's meant to yeah
yeah yeah I also feel that when you're
in pain in like any kind of pain
especially the pain they're in you're
probably just like dude I just need
someone to blame it on somebody needs to
pay for this to make me feel better it
makes it makes sense somehow yeah dude
well it's dangerous anyway like kids
shouldn't be with strangers like we tell
kids all the time don't get stranger
danger but ubers are so normalized rates
and stuff you know so like what are they
gonna do to it actually a kids suberin
yeah right Sheriff it's for kids only
and I downloaded the app too and but the
the downside to that is that you have to
request the right 24 hours in advance oh
so your parents can check no so all the
all the people driving they're all like
nanny certified it's usually women and
so like as a parent like I would feel
safe letting Isaac take it take a ride
there but the fact that it's 24 hours in
advance I'm like pointless
yeah it's pointless because most of the
times where I'm like [ __ ] like it would
be perfect if Isaac could get it right
to this thing right now but it's always
like at the drop of a hat like yeah yeah
I had like that for things like that
that's right
I guess after reading the story I'm like
what the [ __ ] like kids are taking uber
by themselves like that's that's crazy
so this is the 12 year old little girl
kind of Philip you know Deva didn't say
anything else about the suicide letter
that's all that I read well she has
looked oh she does look like Philip you
know why yeah these are the parents so
they're just they're planning to sue
over over that and they're just hoping
like you know that this doesn't happen
dude that sucks or the driver too ya
know to be like the one who caught that
right yeah well so they're looking to
see like who's to plaint who's to blame
here that's like saying you know we're
gonna we're gonna sue the the paper
company what she wrote the letter in
because if she wouldn't have had a paper
you know she wouldn't know how to let
yeah you know it's it's just trying to
place blame on anyone at that point yeah
there's this one over driver that was
being interviewed for this story and
they wanted to be anonymous because they
don't want to need hey and so they said
that there was this one time that they
declined to give a 14 or 15 year-olds
ride to school and so he reported that
account for being an unaccompanied minor
and then he drove around the corner and
waited and cuz he was like you know I'm
just curious to see what happened so he
waited four to five minutes and another
uber showed up and then that driver took
them [ __ ] so it's not like uber did
anything about it
no yeah even though you report again it
doesn't even mean anything
exactly maybe this lawsuit is good
though because even though it has
nothing to do with that driver and it's
not the driver's fault
like ubers gonna learn a lesson that
they need to make whatever you know
rules have been going on yeah like it
shouldn't be advantageous for them to go
ahead and take those children's yes of
the drivers that are being interviewed
for this they're saying like you know
yeah the whole thing about being
incentivized to not cancel rides is one
thing because you're now you're playing
with my money yeah then the other thing
is that they're painting uber to be just
plain out greedy they're like you know
what if this kid wants to take a ride
who the [ __ ] are we to say no like
there's like you know we want to take
the money and it's how many times out of
the right is that a bad right like I'm
telling you my brother takes who were
all the time because we're like hey dude
I'm busy I'm working my sister's here my
mom's here just taking over you know
like literally from here to there it's
not a big deal he gets home we're all
happy you know hey I'm gonna go to my
friend's house oh he's taking over you
know he has his own over uh so jealous I
hated being a teenager and always asking
my like yeah I used to take the bumpy
team growing this minibus
I wish there was about so dangerously
yeah
way more down my ass crap so like at
least twice as a teenager yeah looking
back now I'm like damn I was bald I
didn't even register as like this is
dangerous I was like yeah I'm doing it
on my own I'm good and I went to high
school and Downey but I lived in South
Gate and we take the bus from Downey all
the way to South you take me like an
hour and a half to get home yeah all
those stops what the [ __ ] was I doing on
the bus so yeah it was a freshman you're
tiny - yeah I mean I'm much rather have
my brother in an uber than in a bus yeah
so I don't want them to cancel those
kinds of rights you know cuz they're so
helpful for other people by busy Manny
he's 16 oh yeah he's about to be 17 but
he's still grown he's kind of grown at
the eyes maybe like 16 and up or
something yeah yeah it like 10 11 12
like they really might not be able to do
anything if something goes wrong you
know so that uber for kids thing is
called hop skip the drive shoutouts I
want you guys to be more accessible
successful because this would prevent
[ __ ] like this I think you know like it
was more managed by parent I would have
been in Manny let's say that girls
schedule in the hop stick dry whatever
no but you need the you need the parents
right but like she did it from her mom's
phone too you know like she like the mom
didn't realize she ordered a ride
imagine if she would have done it and
then the nanny drops her off at the at
the building she's not asking her what
are you here for so that I love hop skip
drive for that reason that they have to
sponsor video yeah they have to as soon
as the person driving the kid when they
drop them off to a place they need to be
dropping them off in a place where they
actually get a signed permit like
they're handing them off to another
adult not like this kid's gonna be left
in LA oh that's why I really like it
because it seems like really really safe
yeah I still haven't used it you suck
dude no 24 hours in advance yeah that's
the only downside for me that the reason
why I haven't used it you know what they
need they need like an uber for women or
like for people who feel threatened like
that you know like work gentlemen
uber yeah they do have those train cars
in Japan where it's women only oh really
is it just beat boomer but they should
regulate better right
yeah like maybe have a background check
on drivers yeah you made it drunk women
uber though then it's like you know the
person driving is like oh I'm only gonna
get drunk woman you could just match
women drivers with women passengers it
would just make a lot of [ __ ] go away
yeah and I'm sure man would be like but
there's so many of us who are not like
that but that less men are gonna be
available to pick you up at any like the
whole convenience of uber like you the
24 hours in advance is because probably
they have way less drivers to have
around well there could still be plenty
of men that pick up men it's just like
women want to have the option yeah to
only get a female driver so that they
know like just like those female only
cars yeah in Japan on the train yeah
while female drivers will feel more
comfortable
driving if it was female yeah passengers
I used to be an uber driver you did yeah
I said I drove for uber and lyft right
when I quit my job before I came out
here yes I needed money before I got out
here and I definitely got sexually
harassed at least once like hardcore huh
and then other times it was just a
little uncomfortable and driving at
nights definitely weird I wouldn't I
wouldn't do it now again yeah and it's
scary to think about like I never would
do it because of that like who's gonna
get in my car what do they have on them
do they have a gun do they and they're
behind you - yeah it's like they're
sitting next to you there's some of them
they'd sit next to me and that's what's
even more scary cuz like the guy that
sexually harassed me was sitting in the
front seat - and I was like oh [ __ ]
it'd be easier if I could stop the car
put it in park and like get out some
[ __ ] went down but he's right here like
he could [ __ ] with me while I'm driving
so that's that was good you didn't have
a gun no you're in Texas girl you can
own a gun I'm [ __ ] no oh
[Music]